يظل الساعه سته
رمضان هكذا وبدردشه بينهما قرر رئيس
البرلمان والحكومه تاجيل العمل بالتوقيت
الصيفي حتى نهايه شهر رمضان المبارك قرار
رسم مشهدا سرياليا على الحياه اللبنانيه
بردود الفعل عليه يعني هالقد في بزنس وشغل
بلبنان لحتى الساعه تاثر عليها مناسبني
انه معظم الساعه لانه نحن صايمين نستفيد
الساعه في لببكه بالايمان وباللاب توب
وبالتليفونات لنشوف شو بدنا نعمل لانه عم
نشتغل نحن كمان مع برا وفي سفر قد يعتبره
البعض موضوعا سخيفا الا انه فتح باب
الطائفيه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
لتبدا الاتهامات باسلمه النظام السياسي
ليرد عليها بعدم احترام العيش المشترك
فيما تبقى المشكله الاساسيه فوض القرارات
والتفرد بها وفي حكم ما في دوله والساعه
موقفه من زمان عنا
هم يا حبيبي التزم اكيد مجبور يعني في
مغيره ساعتها انا بمشي على سيارتي والبلدي
يمشي
مقررت مؤسسات عده عدم الالتزام بقرار مجلس
الوزراء واعلنت انها ستبدا بالعمل
بالتوقيت الصيفي في وقته الاساسي كشركات
ومطاعم ومدارس ومؤسسات اعلاميه فيما شركه
الطيران الشرق الاوسط الطره الى تعديل
مواعيد كل رحلاتها بعد البلبله التي حصلت
اهدا اول شيء اما لا يتعلق بتدبير حكومي
وانما ارى بين اثنين ما فينا نلتزم باذر
لانه كل الدراسات العالميه بتشير انه على
الاقل بدك سنه قبل لحتى تبلغي الجهات
المعنيه وخصوصا الجهات المعنيه بالتوقيت
انه هي بلغيها بالاذاب الذي يمكن ان يتخذ
ثم نحن نتضرر كتير من هالامر لانه نحن عنا
ارتباطات بمشاهدين بكل انحاء العالم احدى
العائلات سترسل ابنها الى في التوقيت
الاول وبعدها بساعه سترسل ابنها الاخر الى
مدرسه اخرى بعد ان امتد الخلاف الى
المدارس هي عينه من الضياع الذي سيعيشه
اللبنانيون مع وجود التوقيتين في بلدهم
ففي بلدان العالم هناك توقيت غرينتش اما
في لبنان فتوقيت صيفي او توقيت بري او
توقيت ميقاتي وحتى توقيت اسلامي او مسيحي
لبنان الذي في الاساس اصبح خارج الزمن
بازماته باتت ساعه من هذا الزمن كفيله
باشعاله طائفيا وكان الشعب يعيش حياه
ورديه ستؤثر عليها ساعه مقدمه او مؤخره
نهج يوسف العربيه بيروت